foreign
to
I suppose
frames and lenses for a moment and also
Jim Whittaker so for those who don't
know the first American to Summit at
first if my research is not not lying to
me and I'm looking at an excerpt from
alumni stories on the
brentwood.bc.ca website and he comes up
and there's a line that I would like to
explore because I think it's Maya
Angelou if I'm pronouncing her name
correctly said that courage is the the
mother virtue that unlocks all other
virtues because of the effectively I'm
paraphrasing here but at the breaking
point you need courage to enact or to
enable those other virtues and there's a
line here and I don't know if it is
Jim's or yours but either way I would
love for you to expand on it pessimism
is an Indulgence Orthodoxy is the enemy
of invention Despair and insult to the
imagination and I I want to bring this
up because
it strikes me that a lot of people not
just very young people but many people
overall feel a certain psycho-emotional
malaise right now a sense of overwhelm
that has led to
pessimism or nihilism and it seems to be
the optimism optimism is the unlock here
so could you elaborate on the pessimism
as an Indulgence and so on in that line
yeah that was actually my line not gyms
you know people are always asking we're
always asking each other are you
optimistic and I kind of feel like
how can you not be optimistic I mean
that's the purpose of life itself and if
you're a father you absolutely have an
obligation to remain hopeful and
given how many gifts we have
surely pessimism does become something
of an Indulgence you know you know we
are we're also caught in the present
these days you know so little sense of
history and we forget how much we've
achieved you know in but when you think
about it Tim in my lifetime women have
gone from the kitchen to the boardroom
people of color from The Woodshed to the
White House
gay people men and women from the closet
to the altar when we think of the
environment when I was a young kid just
getting people to stop throwing garbage
out of a car window was a great
environmental Victory nobody spoke about
the biosphere biodiversity now these are
terms familiar to school children so
what's not to love about a world capable
of such social Transformations that's
scientific genius you know just think
about
that moment on Christmas Eve 1968
when Apollo went around the Dark Side of
the Moon and emerged to see for the
first time in human history not a
sunrise or a moon rise but an earth rise
and in that incredible moment we
suddenly saw the Earth as it is not this
infinite Horizon but a fragile
Blue Planet as the astronauts famously
reported floating in the Velvet void of
space and I think everything has changed
with that you know like a flash of
Illumination it swept over the world you
know we never will think again about the
natural world in the same way we did
before that vision and even today as I
mentioned earlier I think the
revelations of genetics showing us
indisputably that race is a total
fiction well that
hasn't really gotten into the Zeitgeist
yet as the moonshot has but it will and
I think that
we're living through
extraordinarily exciting times
an extraordinarily challenging times but
as I say to all young people what
generation has ever come of age in a
world at peace a world without troubles
you know it's it's very interesting one
of the ways I Tim keep my optimism you
know my my dad wasn't a religious man
his Spirit was broken in the war I never
saw the inside of a church in his
presence but he did believe in Good and
Evil and he used to say to me there's
good and evil in the world take your
pick and get on with it and it was
incredibly wise because we had this sort
of thing in the Christian tradition
particularly that if we just wait long
enough Good's gonna triumph over evil
and we'll all somehow be dissolved and
the Rapture will ain't gonna happen and
famously in the medieval times if you
asked the obvious question if God's
all-powerful why does he allow evil to
exist you were burned at the stake for
heresy right but in the Indian tradition
The Vedic tradition by contrast when
Lord Christian was asked said very
question if God's all powerful why does
he allow evil to exist in the universe
Lord Krishna said to the disciple to
thicken The Plot In other words good and
evil walk hand in hand you're never
going to lose one you've got to take
your side and the the purpose of life is
not to triumph over evil but keep
pushing the wheel of Justice forward and
when you realize that that is the end
point you then never expect to win and
if you never expect to win you're not
disappointed when you lose and because
of that you can keep fighting with the
same idealism the same energy when
you're 69 years old as I am today that I
had when I was 20 years old and marching
against the war in Vietnam